christopher hitchens what is your view
about the American literary community's
response to the death warrant issued by
the Ayatollah against the author of
Satanic Verses Salman Rushdie well
tomorrow is the birthday of George
Washington and tomorrow the shopping
malls of the United States which contain
now one third of the book outlets in
this country will will of their own
volition not settle that book because
they are scared of a foreign despot now
in my opinion for that to happen in this
country on Washington on Washington's
birthday to be scared of a crazy foreign
tyrant this way is a really serious
challenge to what we think of as the
safe assumption a free speech and free
inquiry free expression and necessity to
defend it and in a way though I find all
this way depressing I welcome it because
maybe we need every generation also to
remind ourselves that it's not a free
ride to have free expression not a free
ride to have a free society and that it
does need to be defended but this has
got off to a very bad start
very bad stuff Christopher Hitchens is
our guests our phone lines are open the
subject is how America in the world
literary community including publishers
is responding to the Salman Rushdie
situation the phone lines are open you
can begin dialing now we'll spend a few
more minutes with our guests and then
we'll open the phone's to you area code
202 six to eight to five to five it's
the number for those of you living and
calling from the eastern and central
time zones those living in calling from
the mountain in Pacific time zones 202
783 to 727 those outside the United
States dial the appropriate country code
and then 202 737 6 7 3 4 is the number
for you the story in The Washington Post
on Saturday this past weekend headlined
silence in the eye of the rusty storm
fear has swept the North American
literary and publishing establishment in
the wake of Ayatollah Khomeini's death
sentence on novelist Salman Rushdie
author of The Satanic Verses even talked
about Canada barring importation of the
books you
want to characterize any of that yeah
look I mean I know that a lot of people
who will in the ordinary way when it's
some imprisoned Czechoslovakian
playwright like Vaslav Havel who's
actually on trial this week or someone
in Chile or South Africa or Poland will
automatically sign there's a list
everyone sort of knows it people you can
call famous American writers will put
their names to a defense of the freedom
of others not so fortunate in this case
some of these people decided to pass and
some of them one of them is quoted in
that story said it was because they were
frightened and for me the most
depressing moment of reading that story
was when Arthur Miller said that Arthur
Miller was a hero to many of us when we
were young before all writers because of
his tremendous bravery in the face of
the McCarthy hearings and the play that
he wrote and the plays and books that
he's written on the theme of free
expression that he should say that he is
scared to associate with the protest
where writers life has been directly
threatened where his books are being
burned and the threat is that he will be
burned to it just makes me very sad now
the same justification I don't think
applies to bookstores like nude Olsen
and Waldenbooks who pulled the book from
their shelves and deprived Americans of
the chance to read the book for
themselves
it's a merely commercial consideration I
wonder they haven't been threatened they
aren't at no one's asked to go on TV and
show their face and say you know give
the Ayatollah the lie and say all right
I don't care what you think I prefer to
exercise my rights and then we have
sorry to drone on Bruce but just one
final thing before so I think it's been
very sad that the the religious leaders
of the country have been so feeble
they've all either said nothing or as in
the case of Cardinal Archbishop O'Connor
of New York have said they think the
book is blasphemous and they've as it
were directed their criticism at the
book instead of calling the Ayatollah
Khomeini a blasphemer for using religion
to mount a contract killing which is
what he's publicly done so that's my
take since you asked all right and we've
got to hear in part because you wrote
this column that appeared in the Friday
the New York Times now who will speak
for rusty what's the reaction you've
gotten to this column well nice of you
to ask I mean it shouldn't be me who
says but actually the response was very
positive I think a lot of people have
rung me from around the country saying
it's what they wanted to read which
pleased me very much I think look Pete
is full of cliches I say all the obvious
stuff all the things that we take in
with our milk we know expression freedom
from fear and so on but there are
certain days when cliches come alive and
I apparently was lucky to publish my
cliches on Friday because Friday last
because that was when people wanted to
move Youngstown Ohio first call Oh
Christopher Hitchens go ahead please yes
I would like to address myself first of
all I am a model but I don't adhere to
the doctrine of Islam my question is
even though I believe absolute freedom
of expression by anybody that is always
a fine line
well accessible intellectual and
educated person like the Maoist II
should really recognize secondly freedom
of the speech does not allow anybody
anybody to be also extremists to the
extent that he felt 1 billion Muslim the
second comment I would like to address
the host of this program I've been
seeing this program for a long time and
I admire it very much but so far every
time there is an issue between Arabs and
Israelis or Muslim and non-muslim you
never ever bring to your program
anybody represent the other of you if
there is really freedom of speech and
you believe in it you should adhere
yourself to it and you should allow the
other side to present their view all
your guests so far they were
representing the opposite view why don't
you allow us we are 8 million Muslims in
America we have a right to be
represented in your program and we have
many Muslim scholars they would like to
present their view and your program all
right sir thank you I'll respond to that
after we hear from
mr. Hitchens um there's a mistake at the
heart of what you say so you say that
there you are for free speech you aren't
for the exercise of free speech if your
defense Muslims and you say that that is
the line that we draw as matter of fact
you're in error First Amendment to the
Constitution allows anyone who wants to
to insult anyone they like in any way
they choose that includes belief in
religion which is especially given no
particular protection by that amendment
which is in fact rightly described as
the cornerstone of our Liberty now
that's just the fact of the matter I can
say what I like about your religion and
you can say what you like about my
humanism and I will not attempt to
prevent you from doing that in fact so
far from that I would defend anyone who
tried to make you be silent that is the
foundation of what we call the
Enlightenment
it's terrible to have to be saying this
because it's ABC but there it is now to
your point about the insult I have read
the book I don't know if you have and
I'm clear in my mind that no insult to
the Prophet or to those who believe in
the god of whom is the messenger is
intended the words that are complained
of are spoken by a sick man suffering
from paranoid schizophrenia in a dream
in which he believes himself to be the
Archangel Gabriel who is a Christian
icon so I think that's about as far
fictionally as you could go to avoid the
charge of blasphemy but I must add that
if someone Rushdie had wished to be
blasphemous and wished to challenge the
tenets of your faith that would also be
his right so don't confuse me in giving
you to anse as I mean them to be
separate but related and to the caller I
would say that we make every effort here
to have a balanced presentation of all
issues I'm certain I know that we've had
representatives from the Arab and the
Muslim worlds both paid lobbyists as it
were and other journalists and the like
perhaps you'd prefer to see a greater
proportion than we've had on or you've
simply missed the ones that you've had
on neither case I urge you to keep
watching and you will see over the
course of time a balanced present issue
presentation on this
all the other issues that come up for
discussion on this program also
Oklahoma's next go ahead please yes
first of all I'd like to know why has it
taken the so long for the US government
to respond to Iran statements of killing
Rushdie and what do you think the United
States will do to Iran for this if
anything's going to be done well it
certainly is true that the first
statement made by Secretary of State
Baker was fantastically weak I mean he
said that he thought that the murder
threat was regrettable which is I think
I don't see really that you could have
chosen a more feeble word than that
President Bush today has I think said
intolerable which is an improvement but
not an enormous one the United States
saw two problems one is you have no
diplomats any more Iran no one to
withdraw unlike the European countries
unlike the European countries who have
no ministerial visits that you can
cancel that are in preparation actually
things could barely be worse plus there
are American hostages in the custody of
people supposedly pro-iranian and
publicly pro mania so that's all
difficult however I do think that
something a little more daring could
have been said about the founding
principles of the American Republic when
they're attacked in this way after all
damage has already been done
Salman Rushdie's had to cancel his trip
to United States that's to say Americans
have already been robbed of the chance
to meet him see him for themselves meet
him at book signings and so on many
Americans have been deprived by other
Americans American bookseller monopolies
of the right to buy the book in other
words we're giving ground to the
Ayatollah just at the point where his
regime is crumbling his revolution is at
a dead end
his credibility is in shreds even in his
own country at just this moment it seems
to me appalling that people should start
crying out before they've been hurt and
giving around to what I described before
would describe again as a foreign despot
we have half an hour left with
Christopher Hutchins before the next
call let me ask you your response to
this argument that those publishers who
are withdrawing the books
those authors who might not be speaking
out having that is it's one thing to
respond to another publisher was banning
a book or to a citizens group but here
we're dealing with a terrorist head of
state that justifies our action well I
don't see where the distinction comes I
mean the fact is that these struggles
for freedom of expression freedom of
speech have always been indivisible
they've often required a victory over
fear that's been they've often I'm
afraid to say it necessitated a
confrontation with people who have
deeply religious ideas it was deeply
religious people who didn't want the
Bible translated into English and burned
the first two or three translators
William Tyndale being the best-known
deeply religious excuse me religious
people tried to prevent Galileo from
pointing out that the earth goes around
the Sun and not the other way around
deeply religious people did it to Sir
Thomas More there are countless other
cases unfortunately if that is backed by
state power that only means it must be
opposed that much more strongly and more
unified way Wenatchee Washington state
go ahead please yes I want to challenge
this assertion that there should be no
restrictions on free speech or unright I
know the news men are all them all
against any restrictions but years ago I
happen to be in New York and horsin well
have had a radio program and on this
program he he talked about an invasion
by the Martians well it created a panic
in New York all the telephones were were
tied up for four hours no no ambulance
of calls cajole sue their Lord knows how
many people may have died just on
Carteret now I want that the your guest
to answer me if he believed that that
was should be freedom obviously yes
question answers itself
Wilson Wells has the right to put on a
play people have the right to behave
like fools and lemmings when they hear
it he had the right actually what that
was was a reaction to the very early
days of radio where there was still
something quite mysterious about the
wireless and
brittish's deploy that messages from the
ether and people weren't very familiar
with it had nothing at all to do with
the exercise of free speech and I'm
afraid to say banning orson welles to
try to stop people being of a panicky
disposition would be wouldn't even
putting the card anywhere near the horse
wouldn't that be the equivalent though
of yelling fire in a crowded theater
which is not a protected speech yelling
fire in a crowded theater is not an act
of drama or literature or
novelistic or any other kind of
production oklahoma city you're an axe
go ahead please
yeah I just wonder what the decision of
Waldenbooks and B Dalton says about the
fact of large corporations controlling
distribution of literature in this
country well I think it shows a
generally depressing tendency towards
monopoly towards corporatization of the
market and towards standardization of
the market and towards the selling of
books as if they were shoes or exercise
manuals or videos or whatever in a way
that's a good thing I mean it means that
you can go to a mall and buy a book
while you're thinking of buying
something else so are the members of
your family doing other things but it
has led to a tremendously restrictive
model for other books and in return for
books being marketed as commodities they
also been put at the mercy of a very
small number of distributors you're a
rather high-profile person in your own
right columnist for the Nation magazine
having written this column that appeared
in the New York Times have you gotten
any threats of any kind no I haven't you
expect any um well I had to say to my
wife what about this I've got to go on
TV and do this in that and what do you
think we have a child and it goes to
school in Washington and I'm in the
phone book by the way
and think it's my right to be infinity
and she said no she comes to a country
where there was a dictatorship once
people came to her house and pushed her
around and the fact is there's only one
way you can respond to it we've had
braver friends than ourselves in the
past in countries of persecution and
ones often wondered well what would it
be like but the fact is we this is not a
fair test all we have to do now is not
abandon the principles we have anyway
nothing heroic is demanded Newton
Massachusetts go ahead please yes I am a
first-time caller and a reader of the
nation and I wanted to first of all I'm
an atheist and I wanted to emphasize the
fact that I have the rid of the right to
ridicule anybody's religion but I would
would absolutely fight for their right
to believe to believe it and I wanted to
get your um your views on Canada's these
hate lawns because I believe they were
put into place because of a person who
wrote some garbage about the Holocaust
not not ever existing and and this is
what happens when bad law goes into
effect because of freedoms to say really
lunacy if somebody wants to publish it I
I just thought I'd like to hear what you
have to say on that yeah look it's
another of my famous cliches I was
describing earlier they come alive at
moments like this you say freedom's
indivisible how many times have you
heard that what it turns out to be true
the law in Canada was indeed passed in
order to protect susceptibilities of
Canadian Jews and and it was used to
prosecute someone who wrote a very
unpleasant pamphlet saying that the
Holocaust have not taken place and was a
Jewish fabrication actually the guy went
to jail now a number of us at the time
wondered if that was a proper use of
laws governing speech and I also
wondered if it would stop there and of
course it never does you give the state
a law like that and what's it going to
do but find it convenient I come from a
country that doesn't have a First
Amendment and I know how that works
often I think Americans don't realize
how lucky they are that they have a
first
that doesn't amount of this I should say
I'd like to add one things about if I
could
Salman Rushdie who is someone I know and
admire has in Britain stuck up
consistently for the rights of the
Muslim minority he's defended also the
rights of Muslim peoples overseas so he
thinks have been carelessly disregarded
or brutally treated by powerful Western
countries he's got a very good record on
all this it strikes me as particularly
hateful that he should be the object of
this murder campaign by by a leader who
claims to speak for Islam
Thousand Oaks California's next go ahead
please if you believe that the decision
by the Ayatollah to go after rice he was
like a blind grab for a scapegoat and
the case of the power a regime that is
losing power in order to help them it
was mean world standing and to confine
all their thoughts for one purpose again
yeah I do suspect that and I thought the
same when the campaign of violence began
which actually if you remember was
shortly before the ayatollahs murder and
and bounty threat in Pakistan it was
very noticeable with people besieging
the American buildings in Karachi were
the sort of people who had just lost the
election the former Muslim extremists
who'd been grouped around and general
zeros dictatorship and who were looking
for a way of regrouping and an issue
with which to appeal to people I think
that something of the same is happening
in Iran Ayatollah Khomeini has called
for many holy wars they need and he's
called on people to martyr themselves
for him in countless ways and and there
are I'm afraid to say heaps of dead and
numberless uncounted unknown graves as a
result of his policy I have the feeling
that the willingness of his people to
take him at his word and martyr
themselves afresh in slackening I think
he knows that too and I think therefore
it's in a sense doubly incumbent on us
not to give in to somebody who is in
fact behaving out of desperation was
that their weakest point was trying to
prevent a reformation spreading to the
Islamic world by
contact from the enlightenment wants to
stop that I think we should be very
forcible in resisting it and trying to
turn the process the other way and to
synthesize with the Islamic world
certain ideas that they don't belong to
Europe they don't belong to America
they're common to humanity that we call
the ideas of the Enlightenment I should
mention that before we go too far along
that in addition to being a columnist
for the nation you're the author of a
book of essays prepared for the worst
what's in it well I'll tell you what's
on it which is on the dust jacket I'm
proud to say this is a recommendation
from Salman Rushdie that you buy and
read it and I hope this doesn't mean
it's pulled from the shelves but it's a
collection of essays about the Reagan
era about Thomas Paine the great
Englishman who became also a great
American and who wrote the crisis and
who in a sense contributed some of the
finer amendments to the Constitution so
it's a it's a general collection of
essays in defense of the ideas of
Liberty if I do say it myself I'm sorry
I'm modest but you ought to mention out
loud your country of origin yes in case
anyone thought it was anywhere else I
was born in the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland I'm English
I've been living here for about ten
years now but I'm told that the accident
is still noticeable mm-hmm
before the next call how do you think
all of this will play out in terms of
the viability of freedom of expression
let's say a year from today well my hope
is that it's healthy that this will in
fact have confirmed people that it's a
sort of exercise that's good for the
muscles that have gone slack we don't
often have to in our very own homes and
malls and shopping centres have to think
gosh what's the price of free expression
I think it might be profoundly
educational I hope it doesn't turn into
just defending ourselves against Islam
or against the Ayatollah because there
are people always in all societies and
this one who would like to tell us what
they think it's okay for us to read very
often using religion as their excuse and
they deserve to be repudiated too as
they were in the past it was necessary
to repudiate them to have
to have the American Revolution so I'm
optimistic if we can get through this
and if Salman is not hurt if his
isolation could be ended and as every
chance I think I think it would have
been good we've got about 20 minutes
left with Christopher Hitchens next call
for him orlando florida you're on the
air yeah I'd like to speak about
terrorism here you know we have the
dirty dozen movies a few years ago and
why don't we send out all our criminals
except for our child molesters and
serial killers and all the real creeps
and send them out the air and fight for
us because this is how our country
started this is how Australia started
tell you what caller do you have any
comment you want to make about the
issues surrounding the price on Salman
Rusty's head and the effect on the best
man has a right to say what he wants to
say and publish a book or do anything he
wants to do we have this right in United
States
but people lie on the stand here in this
country they go out to courts and they
see police officers line yes ma'am but
I'd like you to make a comment regarding
the very purpose of Christopher Hitchens
visit here today do you have a comment
on that subject yes I don't okay people
have also a right to be honest but
honesty doesn't work does it it's proven
all across the world that if you're
honest you're a victim all right ma'am
thank you very much comment nothing you
me Jews
Washington DC is next go ahead please
yes I think that one of the most
important elements here that it is not
being talked about so much is the
internal situation in Iran which is the
prime reason how many has involve itself
in this ridiculous show I think in the
past six months how many has killed
somewhere around 12,000 of the opponents
in Iran and it is indeed
because he doesn't have the issue of war
anymore at hand and I think that Romania
is trying to here use this issue to
somehow divert the attention from his
really poor situation inside Iran and
the most interesting thing that I find
in this whole episode is that this idea
of I think moderates and hardliners are
really ridiculous and as long as
Khomeini regime is in power we're going
to have the same sort of terrorism and
ridiculous things under the name of
Islam and Muslim and I'm really opposed
to this whole show and I was wondering
what's your opinion of this idea of
moderate and hardliners thank you
yeah well that's an admirable statement
and it may possibly have come from
somebody tuned in late because I had
been saying earlier so that I did think
this was this campaign both in Pakistan
and in Iran originated from political
extremists conservative forces who felt
their hold on the situation to be
slackening and I agree with what you say
about that especially in view of the
fact of the Great Crusade the great holy
war in which so many Iranians to lose
their lives is now over and hasn't come
out as the Ayatollah wanted or predicted
that it would of course you're right
about the moderate business and and the
earlier caller who asked me why I
thought the US government had been so
silent and rather shamefaced on the
question and he prompts me to give her
another answer now I mean I think there
is still in high circles in Washington a
tremendous embarrassment about this
absurd pretence that they were dealing
with people who they're moderate were
extremists enough to deal only in
weapons and I just say that people
should blush about that there are I mean
indeed there have been some I've had
debates on in public with Reaganites who
in a sense defend the ayatollahs
position and say of course he can
campaign
that's mean if he wants to people that
pat buchanan who was reagan's
communication secretary at that point
but he I think was speaking to Cannon as
to say as a religious extremist himself
and one who sees a solidarity between
them that you know overcomes
denominations that's why I began by
attacking the statement made by John
Cardinal O'Connor yesterday but usually
if you criticize a religious leader in
America you get people ringing up all
the time but no no one yet well we've
still got 14 minutes but let me ask you
you characterized you told us what was
in the book you've read it you want to
offer your own critical view as to
whether it's a good read it's a good
novel good story yeah I did actually
review it in in print about but in a
small magazine about two weeks ago and I
said the following I mean Russia is a
genius with language but there's a
difficulty which if you're starting the
book today you should bear in mind he's
got an absolutely magnificent ear and
his ear is brilliant at catching the
nuances and the tone of people to speak
in Indian Pakistani sub-continental
English he's fantastically good at this
makes almost poetry out of the prose
unfortunately that's not very well
understood here as it is in England
there aren't that many people from the
subcontinent in America so the first
couple of chapters may not strike you as
being as funny as they really are but I
think by the third you may well be
hooked but do do persist and I think you
also find that the remarks made about
religion are all carefully judged
remarks about Dogma about people who
have automatic unthinking faith and no
one who has any genuine devotional
attachment to any religion could be
offended Eugene Oregon go ahead please
Johnny um yes if Russia is in fact
killed what response would you predict
Britain or the United States to take or
or what kind of action could they
feasibly take there's no way of
retaliating in time you see it's it's
the whole difference between our use of
the word martyr or heretic and the use
by fanatics of those words when we say
heretic we quite often mean an honorable
thing many of our greatest
political and historical heroes have
been people who willing to brave the
charge of heresy the same with martyrdom
we say our faith as humanists doesn't
require the creation of martyrs we can't
argue with people who appear to need to
create them we can't say we'll go and
kill an Iranian scribe that would be
obscene even if it was doable I think
I'm very reluctant to answer the
question without thinking about it very
carefully but what I think is this if
that happens by and I don't believe it
will because I think this is a dying
regime and a fanatical despairing
maneuver on its part but if a hair of
his head is hurt or if let it be
forbidden he should be killed I think it
would lead to an enormous revulsion in
the Muslim world which might in the long
run contribute to the Reformation that
that world so obviously needs and I
can't speak for mr. Rushdie but I think
he hopes in any case that this
controversy may help to bring know about
Binghamton New York you're on the air
thank you for Chris positions and
there's a couple points in your first
answer you said as I think basically
everyone have read on the problem is
that blasphemy is not really happening
that is it is the dream of a demented
person now
my sense is very strongly are not
religious it is quote blasphemy unquote
in relation to religious but and I think
that most of the critics are kind of
hiding and not coming forward I think
Rushd himself I can understand that you
will try to say it is not but it is it
is a very heavy criticism the second
point is something that has not been
brought up at all in discussion it's
always remaining on the religious level
if there is a wonderful subplot
concerning the Imam sitting in
Kensington and going back
it is to a country called - industry in
the case of the book but it is obviously
Ayatollah is the image those two things
I think are if you have an inner well
you get a very good class of question
from Binghamton I must say SUNY I'm over
yeah I've been up there once and I
remembered it's the same hometown yeah
it is
well that's me look the word muhammd
is used in the novel and my handi is for
those who haven't read this yet an
extremely abusive term leveled against
the Prophet Mohammed by the Crusaders
centuries ago implying that he not just
had failed to be the messenger of god
but that he was actually an emissary of
the devil it's therefore it's an in
tremendously just to use the word is
that is enough indeed to offend people
who don't want to inquire any further
but the word is specially used in a way
that satirizes its use
someone says in the book look I use it
just as so many other words began as
terms of abuse Impressionist for example
the gun is a term of abuse for the
school of painting that object
suffragette was a term of abuse for
campaigners for women's rights black was
a term of abuse at one point the words
Tory and Whig political party names both
began as terms of abuse people took the
names on themselves as a way of drawing
the sting if you see what I mean as a
way of inverting them and turning them
back as satirical ironic weapons against
the intolerant that's what he's
attempting to do it's a very honorable
enterprise it's perfectly justifiable to
try when we could go even further into
this but I I did also said at the
beginning and I do still insist that if
he had wanted simply to be offensive and
to say this religion is nonsense as far
as I can see that's also his right
Columbus Georgia you're on the air um I
was born and raised in the Middle East
I'm not Christian I'm not margin on the
Christian
it seems to me like the West we don't
understand the Islamic world period I
have a couple of things I'd like to
mention the the Muslim world or the Arab
world always looks at the waste with
suspicious because though it's never
accepted the fact that Mohammed is the
final word from God to mankind the
second thing the Muslim leaders or the
Muslim leadership in the its in the Arab
world or Iran or anywhere in the world
Islamic world use the scare tactics to
scare the followers and they rally their
followers by scaring them ho ho used
religion for political motives for their
own benefit I don't think really
anything wrong with their wish this book
by expressing his opinion but then you
take the percentage of the educated
people in that part of the world the
ones they read the book they value the
review and the ones they read it public
can understand as well but they use it
for their own benefit to manipulate the
public opinion in their own countries to
to rally the support for the failing
regimes like humanism and so forth so I
think you know we have to look at their
background how they think and how they
operate and take actions according to
their actions not how we'd like to be
judged but how they judge us in the West
are according to their standards not
power standard okay so thank you yeah
fair observation I mean but I would
strengthen a bit what you say about they
haven't read it and and may not have
understood it even if they have they
can't have read it it's not available
even in English in the Muslim world and
most people who was in world speak
either Arabic or Farsi or audio and it
hasn't been translated into any of those
and then you have to remember that
unfortunately these regimes coexist with
a very very high level of illiteracy
furthermore and finally there's a
commandment that you don't read such
books if you're told they're unclean or
impure or blasphemous so they're they're
about four or five reasons why these
people and their leaders cannot know
what they're talking about now that in a
way is what's frightening about this
challenge because it's a
challenge that is proud of being
ignorant thus one with which it's very
difficult to compromise Los Angeles
California
yes my concern is not necessarily with
the First Amendment right which we have
in which we use freely my concern is
with the publishers and with the
bookstores and as an author I was
wondering if this gentleman could make
any suggestions as to how we might apply
pressure on those entities who in fact
are really denying me my right by no
longer publishing it and no longer
selling it by it
sar have you tried to buy the book yeah
and what were you told it's not
available you tried it in the change
stores
yeah what about independent stores I
know I have it well I think there's some
good advice in yesterday's New York
Times from someone with whom I almost
never agree though I admire him as a
writer William Safire who says go browse
Abby Dalton and go browse at Walden
books and see what you want to buy and
then go to your nearest independent
bookstore and spend your money there
that's the best way to punish them it's
a little extra trouble but I think worth
it and it is the only language currency
that they understand then I think and
hope we may hear soon from the Penn
Organization which groups American
authors and international writers of
some bankable famous authors who will
say they don't want their books sold in
these chains too there is talk of this I
mean that's the most I know for now with
that I think would be a very fitting
reply what's your response to the
argument of the chain owners who say
we're just trying to protect our
employees and our customers well my
response would honestly be that Jews
have to be paid they make a good living
out of the fact we have freedom of
speech so do I it's how I make my living
but I recognized that that doesn't come
from the sky wasn't given me by God it's
the result of a willingness to sacrifice
but people earlier on the Jews were
asking how to pay or not very great they
haven't been threatened for one thing
there is no threat against the
distribution of the book the injunction
does not apply to them the injunction
applies to the author and his publisher
so they're crying before they've been
heard second if they worry about
security deal with the security
but you don't you don't make us any more
secure by removing the book Silver
Spring Maryland go ahead please yeah I
don't want to talk about blasphemy or
the Muslim mindset what I really want to
say is that this reminds me of the
reaction we have a lot of Americans sit
around every time we have a book on the
Holocaust and they say how did all those
good Germans let it all happen well it
happens when we have a commission on
pornography and Playboy and penthouse
disappear from 7-eleven and Kmart and
then it happens with this kind of thing
happening with the bookstores and and
the fear and we're so self-righteous
about other people who didn't stand up
and be counted and when we're asked to
count we turn tail and run so often and
freedom isn't going to laugh that way
thank you Silver Spring well-put but
they're always people like yourself
Madame evidently which is the
encouraging thing I mean that's that's
much more to the point
there are variably people that the lady
who just called to say no no I'm not
going to be treated like this I'm not
going to be told what think I will
decide that for myself in the end that
idea is going to win because it's more
more democratic or intelligent it's more
modern it's more efficient to think like
that and to be permanently under a
mental now we've got enough time to talk
more about the ten organization and when
their plans are you a member I'm ashamed
of Sam not a member but they've gained
one member by this it's another thing we
thought I'll pay the Jews one day and I
will now what they're doing is tomorrow
in New York City and I believe today on
the west coast holding public readings
from the book with authors stepping to
the microphone in relay holding the book
and reading from it and establishing the
right for it not just to be written but
to be heard and read which is you know
part of the right and that'll happen in
New York City tomorrow morning at noon
in the downtown gallery and will be
carried but I think on TV I hope so
everyone there will put their names to
saying we affirm this about the book and
then we'll see if anyone wants to add us
all to the list but I don't believe it
I think we have to face it and say this
is this is a stupid wicked bluff and
that there's no reason for anyone to act
scared about this sort of intimidation
Christopher Hitchens columnist for the
nation and author of a book of essays
prepared for the worst is that in the
stores now yes it is yes now involved
from the shelves as over the state the
folio to more in the stores than I'd
like out of the stores and into the onto
the bookshelves of the reading public
that's my slogan Thank You Christopher
Hitchens in return and to our audience
thank you for watching thanks for
calling and have a good evening